die lutherstadt wittenberg die wiege der
reformation
hier schlug martin luther seine
berühmten 95 thesen an und hier begegnet
man heute noch dem großen reformator
fast leibhaftig in gestalt von bernhard
naumann
der 58-jährige ist gerne als martin
luther auf den straßen unterwegs und
macht so werbung für seine kirche und
das ist sie die stadt und pfarrkirche
sankt marien in ihren mauern predigte
martin luther vor 500 jahren als
verwalter ist bernhard naumann für das
gebäude verantwortlich
auch finanziell gerade jetzt eine
riesenaufgabe 78 millionen euro kostet
die generalsanierung um hilfe ruft würde
die ganze welt automatisch helfen sie
tun es zum teil aber es ist nicht leicht
es ist nicht einfach
die stadtkirche sankt marien ist das
älteste gebäude der rund 50.000
einwohner stadt wittenberg die unesco
ernannte es zum welterbe um die kirche
zu erhalten wird sie seit 2010 saniert
der kirchen meister ist seitdem viel auf
der baustelle unterwegs
denn die zeit drängt es sind nur noch
wenige jahre bis zum großen ereignis dem
reformationsjubiläum im jahr 2017
die außenarbeiten sind abgeschlossen
zurzeit wird gerade der innenraum
saniert
die
viele der kirchen schätze verbergen sich
hinter planen und abschreibungen haben
seine 2000 predigten gehört die hre
gehalten hat hier drin hat er geheiratet
und vor allen dingen hier war der erste
evangelische gottesdienst von dem alles
ausgeht
die planen verdecken auch den berühmten
cranach altar bald soll er wieder im
original zu sehen sein
lucas cranach der ältere einer der
wichtigsten maler der renaissance
fertigte ihn an
auf den berühmten werk mischte er die
wittenberger reformatoren luther und
melanchthon in das altarbild die
sanierung solcher werke ist aufwendig
und teuer
bernhard naumann versucht mit
ungewöhnlichen aktionen die spenden
kassen zu füllen
unterstützt wird er dabei vom populären
deutschen opernsänger gunther emmerlich
gemeinsam versteigern sie kirchen
mobiliar vorbild oder herausragend
also wichtigtuerisch sondern unter dem
motto tue gutes und rede drüber
deswegen reden wir ja auch darüber damit
viele leute das zur kenntnis nehmen und
vielleicht auch geneigt sind uns dabei
zu helfen
gunther emmerlich ist schirmherr der
spendenaktion zugunsten der kirche hat
er sich auch auf eine wette eingelassen
dass das die wittenberger und ihre gäste
natürlich nicht schaffen mich im geld
aufzuwiegen
diese wette gehe ich ein der gewinner
steht jetzt schon fest denn am ende geht
es allen hier um den erhalt der
berühmten kirche
ich bin ich jetzt sagen dass man jedes
mittel recht ist ganz sicher nicht aber
ich denke die sanierung dieser mutter
kirche der reformation zu unterstützen
und dafür zu werben das ist ein so gutes
tun dass ich das mit bestem gewissen
auch gerne in dieser diese robe machen
das fehlende geld wird schon noch
zusammenkommen meinte bernhard naumann
und ist auch in diesem optimismus martin
luther ziemlich ähnlich